all right
i don't know i did the nick cage thing i
was trying to do a tom cruise thing
what's wrong we're here
for the honest trailer commentary for
top gun maverick uh the number one film
of the year box office wise but in our
hearts stick around we're going to talk
about it we're going to watch you on
this trailer together i don't know um
we will do we have some deleted scenes
to watch uh we have uh some q a from the
audience so keep those coming in the
chat and then we will tease you with
next week's honest trailer per usual um
top gun maverick uh
wow wow what an experience what a
cinematic experience wow um
it was great uh it was great and um
if nothing else uh it just proves that
um tom cruise for all for whatever his
personal uh foibles and things maybe uh
really gives a [ __ ] about his movies man
he's still got it he's still got it he's
got that infected
but uh i don't know there's not much
left to say because this movie's been
talked about for a long good long while
uh and it's like almost almost
universally beloved um
not not fully and we can get into why it
is and why it is and then things that
even we didn't uh didn't fully get on
board with but uh
in a world of
superhero sequelitis and um just bad
legacy sequels it was very refreshing to
see something that had a lot of care and
craft uh put into the action and the the
visual of the film and also the way it
woven
uh its own legacy into the sequel was
very well done and uh
that's that's all there is for me to say
about top gun maverick yeah it's great
yeah it was great uh those planes look
like they're humping and that was very
nice
they do they look like they're humping
um yeah everything about it looked
amazing it was entertaining it didn't
you know it's something that we talked
about it it's not doing that same like
haha not not wink wink thing it's
actually oh we're using our call signs
now yeah it actually feels like sincere
which sincerity is kind of rare
these days yeah they they introduce us
to this new cast and they don't do the
legacy sequel trap of having the new
cast has seen top gun and they're
riffing on it the whole time like
they're those those characters aren't
just there to be like remember iceman he
was the best they have their own stories
and their own narratives to play out and
that is that it's it's better to do it
that way i think than the ghostbusters
afterlife approach of like let's make
this whole movie a celebration of the
legacy of the other movie and it just
becomes references it's sad but it's
like they showed a lot of restraint by
not having like hangman buzz the tower
because like he wouldn't because he
didn't know that maverick used to do
that exactly or somebody to like bite at
another person because they wouldn't
know that iceman did that but a lesser
film would have been
non-stop bites and i and i referenced
that on twitter people got back to be
like well there are a lot of those
moments there is like an inverted
reference
beach volleyball gets a call back in
beach football but character wise it
makes sense that maverick would be like
well this worked for me yeah so i'm
gonna do it again that's exactly it they
recontextual they take the time and care
to recontextualize those moments in this
new film so it's not just hey remember
that goose used to sing great balls of
fire it has new poignancy because now
maverick's watching him play it from
outside he's on the outside of that
situation that he used to be part of and
it's part of the theme of the new movie
and that's just like it's a it's good
storytelling it's just back to basics
meat and potatoes that's basically
potatoes
yeah um
i do think that there is a certain
timelessness about it in a kind of eerie
way where it's like uh time has frozen
and we're in we're in 1989 or when was
first top gun 87 86 somewhere around
there
where like the there's a bar that
doesn't allow cell phones and they're
playing great balls of fire whichever
which clearly lawrence from friggin
insecure knows all the lyrics yeah great
balls of fire yeah can i just also say
the the rule
that's not an enforceable rule first of
all that bar is the size of a dave and
buster's it's massive
it's massive if you were gonna pay for a
round of drinks for everyone in that bar
at a time that's like a thousand dollars
at least well we talked about this
earlier and i think that this was a
covedera policy to kind of get through
the lean months where they had to have
more sales than you like if this was a
bar where there's like four people like
if this was nate's lizard laughter this
is the world's largest dive bar yeah
then you could like okay treat those
three guys to a beer i okay that would
be a policy you could enforce this is
ridiculous but i think you're like
whatever the closest bar is to a
military base probably does a brisk
business in alcohol
i have to imagine they're they're gonna
do they're gonna do pretty great that's
some prime real estate you'd have to put
that sign like prominently above the
front door to make sure people really
knew about it but it's not you can't
spring that on people just quick to
aggression before we get into the quick
digression from this massive diagnosis
for the turtle racing sure yeah well
okay danielle do you know what i'm
talking about no okay so it's in santa
monica venice one of those yeah it's
like border of santa monica and
venezuela there's a lincoln yeah they
they do this thing where they put a a
bunch of turtles in the center of a big
circle and you know they do have the run
fair yeah and it's got the circle the
circle's got they do do it at red pairs
and then there's circles got like is
that a renaissance yeah there's like
concentric circles in this making uh
animals do things they don't want to do
is definitely yeah you put all the
turtles
you see which turtle got the closest to
the center
you set them all on the edge
but they have this thing where if you
pull out your cell phone during the race
you get that you have to pay five or ten
bucks or something like that which is
almost uh which is guaranteed money
because you know it's like it's like a
hitting your uh knee with a hammer like
people's hand just goes through their
pocket and pulls out a phone when you
see a bunch of turtles yeah but the
animal's doing something like that
so every time they're just collecting
you know five dollar bills they do they
announce that they they make sure it's
known it's not just like hey there's a
little wood carving behind the bar like
what are you pulling here connolly this
is what people came here to watch uh
i got really upset about the the
jennifer connelly pulling that out on
people any humiliating them after the
kids hey with her body
she was she was we'll get in all that
more let's watch
[Music]
from the only movie star who's resisted
the cult of superhero movies because you
know one at a time comes a smash hit
full of real planes real sets and real
action he may have really started a war
at the end there guy takes his craft
that seriously
top gun maverick um yeah i think this is
let's jump ahead to actually a question
that came in as um
uh benjamin bramwich said uh we
mentioned superhero fatigue law for
seven years is the success of a film
like maverick going to be what ends
comic book film since it has real action
minimal cg and no wings at the camera
i i don't think that this is something
that you could replace and just crank
out you know a bunch of top gun
mavericks no i don't know i know they're
going to try with beverly hills cop
colin axel foley that they just
announced
but that was why it worked the
character's name after the cold that's
what that was
you can't copy
working really hard
and trying really hard to
create no please please copy that cobra
colon marion cabretti
yeah i think that the if the lesson
taken from this is let's get all the
olds uh back together for one last ride
they try that all the time and it
doesn't work um indy 5 is uh is one
that's on my watch list
well that is that's james mangled i mean
i think a lot of the secret here is uh
kozinski directed the hell out of this
thing uh and he's a guy that already
cruz brought in two guys that he's
already worked with and knew that he had
good collaborative relationships with
because in the the script had a pass by
uh christopher mcqueary who does the
mission impossible foes i think both of
those guys you can see
those past collaborations and what they
do well in this movie and they insisted
on doing it it being jets for real
because you could have just put people
in a
fake cockpit with a green screen and it
would have been fine um they would they
could have cut back and forth but they
really put them in the back seat of
these fighter jets and filmed and made
like a tiny camera with its like body
shaped off so they could fit it by the
stick that they would hold and they
really were flying around and that like
tricks the eye in a way that effects
can't um
and the performance is like yeah you
could see the the gravity the g-forces
pulling on their face it does add to the
realism but it's also you get up like no
not to lewis pullman i'm sure he's a
great actor but you're getting a real
performance it really looks like when
the blood drifts from lewis pullman's
face they know what that feels like
they're experiencing it so they can
reflect it in in the camera in a way
that a performance just couldn't so i
don't think that that's something that's
uh copyable
um but hey go ahead try give it a shot
let's do days of thunder for real
cool trickle yeah very nice uh i i
almost got it um
i was just also gonna say i don't think
this is gonna like i i don't really
think this is gonna impact superhero but
i i think this is just a superhero
movies are gonna die a death of their
own accord yeah like they're they're
doing their own they're doing their
thing i don't i don't really i think i
think this movie kind of exists in its
own world apart from the marvel and the
dc and all that yeah all right let's
keep going
tom cruise returns his iconic role as
maverick for a film about how tom i mean
maverick may be old the future is coming
and you're not in it but i mean maverick
won't go down that easy you kind of said
it for extinction
maybe so sir
but not today because tom i mean
maverick refuses to die no matter how
many dumb stuns tom or mab pulls for
mission impossible or the navy or
whatever
teachers have been telling us their jobs
are hard for years but now a blockbuster
will make their complaints look
interesting watch maverick have to teach
the next generation of full-grown adults
who go by their gamer tags phoenix
hangman playback fanboy to forget
by the book we didn't put it in but i
thought it was funny that um
uh i granted i don't know the backstory
that there were two pilots whose names
were harvard and yale
that were their call signs it's like of
course they couldn't keep themselves
from telling people that they went to
harvard
uh what would your would your call sign
be oh wow uh
there's a great joke from the critic
where they're all picking their trucker
handles and he picks cindy asked and
that's what he puts up inside so that's
where i'm gonna go
yes
i like it i like it um probably just dan
rad i'm real
yeah there you go
yeah how about you um
let's say smooth jazz
spoon jazz yeah um yeah we got mr lux
move jazz
um and then i'd be like and away we go
it could be like jazzy for sure where's
jazzy where's jesse i don't see him yeah
yeah
i like it let's keep going
forget playing by the rules it's
dogfight football offense and defense at
the same time and you know what sure
just remember thinking entirely life's
easier that way don't think just do it
don't think just do don't think just do
it don't think
just do what the hell were you even
thinking you told me not to think
oh
the most important lesson of all if you
ever get in big trouble call your boss's
boss to yell at them you get yourself in
trouble ice man makes a call
and you're back in the air for reasons
known only to the almighty and your
guardian angel
you've been called back to top gun
thank you for your service daddy
speaking of nepotism maverick will take
goose's son rooster under his wing he's
determined to follow in his father's
footsteps and entire face but first he
must let go of blaming maverick for his
father's death and maverick must make
lieutenant rooster less of a [ __ ]
increase to 500
negative yield
uh that's not really what the story's
about but couldn't resist that punch
making lieutenant rooster less of a [ __ ]
yeah just too funny
you had two good lines there because you
also had uh what's the matter lieutenant
rooster chicken
that was what it was really about is how
scared uh rooster was to to fly fast
enough yeah he was he was always holding
back a little bit maybe because
you know he thought maverick didn't
really believe in him or you know like
yeah definitely the power of like
believing in you right it was like once
once he knew maverick really believed in
him that he could do it then he was able
to push himself yeah i'm wondering like
was this movie missing meg ryan do you
think
i
wouldn't have minded a meg ryan
appearance i kind of thought i was
hoping we might kind of thought we were
going to get like they kind of set me up
to where i thought we were going to
maybe get a surprise third act ryan
right
and i thought i thought there might be a
third act right because she figures into
the plot because it's like she wanted
rooster to not follow in his dad's
footsteps but she kind of outsourced
that job to maverick we even see her
very quick there is a flashback to the
whole goose family together where she's
featured very briefly yeah yeah because
i thought maybe
like it would have been a possibility
that she comes in and she's like yo i
was like wrong like this is what he
wants right we we broke it now we got to
fix it or just to see where she thanks
maverick for you know like
getting him shut down
before that but like i know that he
hates you because you did this for me
and yeah thank you for cutting my son
exactly
thank you for cucking myself
a great hallmark card too
they have a great collection
keep playing
hold your speed rooster relate with 20
seconds behind and drop it come on
rooster you got him drop down and take
the shot
too late you had your chance
damn it yeah rooster is a pretty lame
call sign but it's still miles better
than bradley bradshaw
math brad brad and the rest of the gang
have just three weeks to pull off
mission extremely difficult your target
is an impact point less than three
meters wide between two mountains
assuming you avoid crashing into this
mountain you'll climb straight up into
enemy radar while losing all of your
airspeed to the point we're using killer
drones seems like the more humane yeah
this is this movie must have such a
tricky
balancing act to do with regards to the
us military that obviously they needed
the support of to get this movie made at
all because it's like
they make the pilots look incredibly
competent but like whoever
but also the military extremely
incompetent because just use a drone
just use a drone
there's no reason why they they've got
it they've got a fictional reason why
i don't remember what it is there is a
we can't we got to use pilots for this
our usual drug because it's in like the
canyon they can't get into that canyon
drones would get shot
yeah there's a macquarie wrote an
explanation and the other thing is i was
like like why can't they use they're
talking about how they're outranked by
like oh they'll be using the fifth
generation fighters or whatever that and
it's like okay the the air force has uh
more modern jets than they're using in
this movie and like why weren't they
using those it's like right because you
can basically just nuke something from
orbit with the new ones it's not
dramatic you're just flying so high you
need to come up with excuses for it to
be the star wars mission yes oh you know
i think it i think it was a battle star
galactica tv show kind of deal where it
was like the new technology there's like
a thing that they could like get into it
right there and they can't
detect yeah
there was an early version of this
script if i recall that was like
maverick versus the drones where it's
like they're being it's more emphatic
like we're replacing pilots with drones
and mavericks like not on my watch but
uh but yeah i imagine he's doing like a
john henry
like he's going to be the one who's a
good pilot well that i mean but that is
like people were like all about you know
this
is this military propaganda that was
like the huge argument and like in the
end the movie really makes the argument
that it's it's tom cruise propaganda
it's not militant it's not like the navy
is the best it's like the only person
who could have done this his time
everybody is
a little weenie who wanted to go slow
the us navy would have failed in this
mission if it was not for one man tom
cruise a superhuman pilot and that's the
message of the film so it's like it is
the military was trying to keep down and
push out yeah everybody hated it they
were totally gonna let goose's son die
yeah like totally like you know these
pilots know what they're signing up for
and tom cruise is like no everyone's
admiring john hamm was like there for
like safety reasons yeah that right
admiral ed harris was ready to kick out
the only weapon the navy really had
tactical tom cruise
ttc uh it's it's it's what we've got
folks uh all right let's keep going
toys yikes but if you want to end your
movie with the high stakes dog fight you
can't go wrong with watching pilots zoom
through a canyon trench staying low
under the enemy guns and aircraft
launching a precision guided missile
down the ventilation shaft of an enemy
doomsday weapon without the use of their
targeting system and surviving thanks to
the last second intervention of a cocky
bad boy even though all they really did
was kick off a much bigger conflict in
the next one they'll reveal a mig-29
with secretly maverick's father
yet
enjoy the rare legacy sequel that
actually works by weaving callbacks and
characters into the story instead of
forcing in cameos and references wait
you can do that any friend or no ghost
like maverick buzzing the tower to save
the jobs of his colleagues
bringing back iceman but evolving their
relationship and the return of kelly
mcgill
i do feel like probably a us military
note is that they had to include some
dweebs from space force
in the first and the first scene there's
like and i hear from space force in my
space force polo also think maverick is
the coolest in the bee's knees
space force
i guess that's a real thing okay
look this is i i haven't been on a
military base in years so i don't know i
don't know the t on space force
i gotta ask i gotta ask my i gotta ask
my dad yeah well there you go um
definitely a real thing beyond that i
couldn't tell you what they're doing but
they're they are real they exist
well huh i think it's still i think
they're still like it's like kind of
still a chunk of the air force right
like
the line between air and space they're
their own thing but
there's a lot of
overlap you know if you have maverick's
like flying up that uh plane then like
like a ufo comes down like this is space
force jurisdiction get out of here the
moment you cross the ionosphere
hold on pull over
all right keep going
yes no and the return of meg ryan's
photograph because you the love interest
actually aged in the last 36 years
instead of whatever it is tom cruise
does to spit in the face of death
let's just pretend that one line about
the admiral's daughter is jennifer
connelly now penny phew that was close
almost considered my own mortality for a
sack pause so strappy some people have
been pointing out in the comments that
um
if you went by the actors ages that
would make uh like maverick 23 and
jennifer connolly's character like you
know 14 or something like that yeah
indiana jones yeah yeah but it's penny
it's not jennifer connolly but still
uh yeah the implication is pretty
strongly that that's why he has to go
penny like that like you're you're
obviously supposed to read that into it
yeah uh
so there you go but without knowing like
i did i don't think you're supposed to
be able to do the math
on jennifer connolly they just just age
her up a few years right she's playing a
few years older than she is um
sarah sarah michelle gallery there you
go she's sarah michelle gellaring
everybody uh there was a a a joke and i
i we didn't go there because it's
obviously uh incredibly mean-spirited
but um is that how funny it would have
been if they had kelly mcgillis in the
iceman role and they were visiting her
like oh man you got old i'm so sorry
oh like she got sorry she got old
i'm gonna go i gotta go back and hang
out with jennifer colley but it was good
to see you
which again that would be more of a joke
on like hollywood yeah we're not making
fun of kelly mcgillis um as as everybody
should um
they get old and they look different
look at us um
yeah
sorry guys one day
uh it's gonna crack yeah we're just
waiting on it yep um all right keep
going
for the ultimate jets go vroom spectacle
that's been called out by the woke mob
for being blatant military propaganda
but they are just butthurt because
america is number one we do nothing
wrong and we have no problems whatsoever
now where's the recruiting booth i want
to play some topless beach football
uss uss uss
starring
captain america the sprinter soldier my
name is bradley bradshaw you killed my
father prepare to fly hulk smashed
d
c k
still pullman
phoenix flight ace aviator
lawrence of arabia
sad martign
depression is caused by the souls of 10
aliens admiral
dick seaman
when they open the movie with danger
zone nice when they don't play take my
breath away damn
g4
there was a perfect time for them to
play take my breath away the love scene
between penny and maverick yeah but but
then we've got a perfectly good uh lady
gaga pendleton
oh did she do the ballot too with the
during the i think i think she did i
think that's why i think that's why she
gets a full like if you see the the she
gets a music credit at the top
i could be wrong about that i am a
little bummed i hope it comes out
eventually or maybe it's out and i
couldn't find it but kenny loggins did
re-record danger zone for this movie um
now that could be bad that could be like
the
fallout boy ghostbusters theme or
whatever but the fact that kenny himself
is stepping back into the ring to do
another date as long as he doesn't like
do up do a wrap in the middle
100 gonna be dubstep behind him
okay never mind that was like
steve miller band got back together to
re-release fly like an eagle but there's
rapping in the back so it's all it's no
good it's not good uh bring on young
gravy
let's not stop
playing
out a big dumb
[Music]
um when the real enemy was right in
front of us the whole time birds
uh someone else point out in the
comments that um not the first time tom
cruise has been on a plane downed by
birds that happened in the mummys mommy
yes
yeah i saw that movie yeah that happened
the birds are their birds are under like
an evil curse in the mummy these are
just innocent birds that are in the
wrong place at the wrong time those
those birds have been sent by a dark
supernatural power but these are
collateral birds these are just yeah
innocent bystander birds
uh all right uh that was the honest
trailer thank you for watching that um
please subscribe to this channel and hit
the like and the bell so that you can
see other things we do like the by the
numbers episode we did for tom cruise
where somebody watched all 43 of his
films and we wrapped up all the uh all
the stats we could we could suck out of
that so you get to see how long he's ran
for what his top speed is um how much he
hangs from things and most impressively
his character's height in every single
film um he's gone from his actual height
five seven to six feet tall in valkyrie
and everywhere in between um so because
you're playing a real guy in valkyrie
yeah you gotta the real von
schtuffenberg or whatever yeah but um
i think vanilla sky he's 511 like he's
he's goes all over the place they should
have really gone and just made him like
six seven for reacher like why did he
use effects technology make gandalf that
guy stretch him out that's right and
then uh we are doing a watch along um
for the rings of power not not the not
those of us at this table today but um
uh some phantom faves maybe we'll get
invited who knows uh that that's this
friday on the twitch channel twitch tv
twitch.tv backslash fandom check that
out hopefully it's good um the watch
long will be great but hopefully the
show is good uh all right now do we have
any outtakes let's see
no matter how many dumb stuns top or mav
pulls for mission impossible or the navy
or whatever
it's okay tom you can rest now
starring
ethan stunt jerry mcflyer
playing man fly nority report literal
whiplash
speed richards
strongbrad
military inferiority complex sailor
swoon
the tender bar
lab rn
scuzzy naval
bob the minion
milton
drink order of the phoenix
strong female character
lawrence fly
wing stop
ice melt
stone valor
general hummel
red ed redemption
mad man
safety never takes a holiday
jackass forever
sky high
mavs and mav knots
planes games and all of the fields
war is hella fun
naval gazing
the rehearsal
yvonne ethniage
people think tom cruise is creepy and
intense in real life but nothing's
weirder than punctuating every single
one of your text messages i mean come on
who does that
yeah the no cell phones rule is bullsh
but how else is penny supposed to cover
rent on a dive bar the size of a dave
and busters
oh yeah we did put that
there you go
uh all right good times uh so much to
say about top gun
who could stop let's see let's get on to
the questions adam halbert asks uh i
love this without having seen the first
top gun is this the best legacy sequel
that you don't need to be familiar with
the previous movie to enjoy
i mean i think it's a rare legacy sequel
you wouldn't have to know because the
others are all constant just like
references and they they're banking on
right you know but this one actually
does do the flashback so it gives you
the context yeah yeah i this is probably
this is probably the best one yeah
probably either that or leonard part six
weirdly i could see someone liking
being confused for all of the the fan
baiting but the but ghostbusters
afterlife just because it's nothing like
ghostbusters
so you can be like true sure entirely
different yeah oh stranger things okay
cool yeah that's true um trying to think
of other ones definitely not the matrix
um just i mean the matrix is really like
i liked it but it is very dependent on
you recontextualizing and understanding
all the riffs it's making on the
original movie scream scream you can
probably keep up uh yeah i mean they're
easy to watch scream sequels without
seeing the first one but they're kind of
diminishing returns all right well let's
see how much we really like it because
damian loads us where does this movie
place on the list of all-time great
sequels just full stop sequel
i'd have to like write them out but yeah
i i would have no problem with this
being in anyone's top 10. yeah i don't
think it's on the left
an aliens or a terminator too maybe but
like it's it's a it's a very solid entry
in sequel history yeah the thing is is i
i would say it's as good as top gun
which is but top gun is not a all timer
for me but it's a super fun 80s action
movie so
that's really damn good that's really
damn good um i would i would have no
problem saying top ten but i'd have to
write him out to see if this is tough
yeah it's a it's a rare sequel that
really does feel like it expands the
world of the first movie in a way that
is satisfying rather than just being
like hey remember that other movie what
if we did you know that again like like
how i think gremlins two another good
example of that of course in two why
yeah why wildly opening the scope of
what the series can be yeah
um let's see so uh
benzy10 says it seems you all liked this
movie you were very gentle with it well
we can't make [ __ ] up that way yeah yeah
it's honest look at his dumb face right
like we have to be honest and if we
liked it that's honest yeah
one opinion says would it have been too
meta to have mav just out of a failed
marriage because he was too singularly
focused on his job is that what happened
with him in kidman is that what they're
getting at uh give goose junior the love
story you could do that sure
um i don't know if that was i wouldn't
have immediately tracked like oh just
like tom cruise too focused on the job
to be married because isn't he i guess
he broke up with katie
he's not currently married i guess i
don't know i don't really know much
about yeah i don't think that that was
the problem but yeah working too hard on
that job i i don't i mean maybe meta is
the wrong word and they just mean like
would that have been a better approach
to the story and like i i don't i don't
know i i think
they kind of had some of that where it
was like
that was the reason why he and penny
were like not together i think it's also
they they do a smart thing which is that
they i we we sort of made fun of the
trying to tie it into the first movie
backstory but they gave it wasn't
maverick met penny for the first time
and then we have to establish this
relationship from the ground floor they
just kind of rested on these two go way
back and they already know each other
well and they already like each other
like if you had if you were giving you
know rooster shows up and he falls for
phoenix and now we've got to establish a
love story between these two you'd have
had to do a lot of heavy lifting
of like them meeting cute and falling in
love and like that's a lot that's that's
four scenes that you don't want to have
to put in there uh james bunt says given
the success of this would you green
light an iron eagle or any of the other
top gun knockoffs reboots i don't think
anything well blonde would just give it
a blanket air america baby yeah um
i mean it's not a not a movie but air
wolf i'd watch an airwolf
uh
a big budget remake it was just like a
cool helicopter yeah i mean i was a
knight rider with a but a but a copter
knight rider would be one i'm in a
permanent state of just expecting all
like where's the delta force movie it's
yeah like i'm just i'm always expecting
all of these things to be announced yeah
um let's see and then yeah one opinion
uh brings up that the uh another filming
reason they weren't going to be allowed
in f35s with actors yeah because they
also that's like a single seat plane and
this one they could do they had the
actual person flying in the front and
then a uh the actor in the back
um
let's see uh
when will we get the honest trailer
green fiend ass for chippendale rescue
rangers the movie that movie was its own
honestly yeah i have nothing to add to
that was one of the more honest they did
all the time hollywood uh yeah they did
all the jokes first uh what it can't
can't joke on a date yeah what do you
what what are we gonna do hat on a hat
on a hat they're making
ugly sonic references yeah
no deeper we can go uh and then finally
matanvalensky says should they get miles
teller to play the maker in the mcu i
mean miles teller he's had kind of some
ups and some downs uh
between you know whiplash and fanfic and
this and stuff like that uh
i wouldn't be opposed to it i'm very
proud of all the fan fourstick kids you
know
not letting it keep them down except for
we still haven't had the return of tranq
quite yet yeah well no he did that
capone movie with tom hardy remember he
did that okay well that movie is wild if
you haven't it's uh i have not it is
i highly recommend he's making movies
yeah he's back he's back in the mix well
great um
kate mara will be fine he's a
billionaire i don't know who uh the
maker is in marvel comics so i mean it
sounds like i'd be fine with miles
teller in the comments but i can't speak
to the maker okay and uh interestingly
like michael uh
yeah miles teller in this movie and uh
michael b jordan and creed they're like
in the two best legacy sequels yeah of
all time for them yeah
that's the only other one that i think
did it as well as this would be creed
right um yes so yeah there you go um
right which is the same thing it feels
like it's part of the rocky franchise
but it doesn't feel like the whole time
it's like huh
yeah we're punching meat we're punching
meat here i i definitely wanted more
time with a robot like like where is
paulie i think yeah if
create three if we're following the
chronology no the the robot's in four
but they already did drago yeah they
already brought a drink we got it's got
to be clubber lang's kid right come on
yeah
just
we got to follow that's with a formula
now
no it's whoever jonathan majors is
playing they've already established he
is not related to cleverland that's a
shame yeah um oh well uh we've already
mentioned next week's honest trailer in
this video so that's your clue go skim
back and see if you can catch it uh and
we will be back next week for that
thanks for watching see you later
[Music]
you